>> Android 1.6 enables applications to be
rendered properly on different display resolutions
and densities. Developers can also specify
the types of screens supported by the applications.
Android 1.6 includes support for CDMA in the
telephony stack. Support for new screen sizes
and CDMA means Android can run on even more
devices and networks. Quick Search Box allows
users to search the web and their phone directly
from the home screen. It provides suggested
results from the web even while the user is
still typing. Quick Search Box provides relevant
contextual information like local business
listings as suggestions without having even
to launch the browser. Users can also find
answers to common queries with Quick Search
Box, for example, local weather. Users can
search for information managed by applications
like contacts. But they can also take actions
such as...
>> Call Adam's mobile.
>> Users control how Quick Search Box works
on their phone. For example, they can select
what types of content is included in their
searches. The search framework provides developers
a way to easily expose relevant content from
their applications. Here's an app for letting
users track what books they have read. The
developer made the app searchable from the
Quick Search Box, by author name and provided
suggestions. Android 1.6 includes a Text-to-Speech
API. This API uses a multilingual speech synthesis
engine that allows applications to speak text
strings with the right accent. The initial
set of supported languages is available to
users from Android Market.
>> Wie geht es dir?
>> In Android market, we're making it even
easier for users to find great apps from developers.
The latest version of Market improves overall
discoverability. Users can quickly choose
among apps, games and downloads. In the category
view, they can explore the Top Paid, Top Free
and titles that just came in. And with each
app or game, users can now see screenshots
submitted by developers as well as read the
reviews from other users. To learn more about
the Android 1.6 release, visit developer.android.com.